This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2022, Americans spent more than $100 billion on lottery tickets. Well millions of Americans are dreaming about winning tomorrow's mega-millions jackpot. Now, the largest and world history surrounds the winner of the 2.04 billion-dollar lottery ticket. The largest of the largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's largest of the world's winner of the 2.04 billion dollar lotto ticket the largest of the Magic Powerball excitement going more than what we've seen over the last week but after another rollover we're now seeing a record jackpot leading to another dash for tickets. From scratchers to the power ball the lottery is the most popular form of gambling in the United States but the likelihood that you will
这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2022年，美国人在彩票上花费了超过1000亿美元。数百万美国人梦想着赢得明天的超级百万大奖。目前，世界历史上最大的彩票奖金正围绕着那张20.4亿美元的彩票得主。这是世界历史上最大的……（重复）……彩票得主，这是魔力强力球带来的兴奋感，比我们过去一周看到的还要多，但在又一次奖池滚存后，我们现在看到了创纪录的头奖，引发了又一轮抢购彩票的热潮。从刮刮乐到强力球，彩票是美国最受欢迎的赌博形式，但你中奖的可能性……
win a lottery like the power ball is about $1.292 million. Statistically, you're more likely to get attacked by a shark, give birth to quintuplets, or even get crushed by a meteorite. You know, the lottery is often called attacks on people who are bad at math. Because this perception that lottery players don't understand the odds against them and have these wishful, hopeful beliefs that a lottery will solve all of their financial problems. That's Jonathan D. Cohen. He's a historian and author of the book for a dollar and a dream, state lottery in modern America. Jonathan says it isn't just that people playing the lottery who irrationally think the game will solve all their
赢得像强力球这样的彩票的概率大约是12.92亿分之一。从统计学上讲，你被鲨鱼袭击、生下五胞胎，甚至被陨石击中的可能性都比这大。你知道，彩票常被称为“对数学不好的人征税”。因为人们普遍认为，彩民并不了解他们所面临的赔率，并抱有一种一厢情愿、充满希望的信念，认为彩票能解决他们所有的财务问题。那是乔纳森·D·科恩。他是一位历史学家，也是《为了一美元和一个梦想：现代美国的州彩票》一书的作者。乔纳森说，不仅仅是玩彩票的人非理性地认为游戏能解决他们所有的……
financial woes. The states running the lottery also suffer from the same delusion. That is, of course, how we have lottery in the first place is voters, policymakers, who believed, wishfully, stupidly, hopefully, that a lottery would solve all of their financial problems, and despite mounting evidence, you know, even after other states it failed and failed and failed again, these voters and policymakers reasoned that a lottery would solve all of their financial problems in the exact same way that gamblers are sort of hooked on this belief that it's going to work for them. Today, we're going to talk with Jonathan about how the lottery got to be as big as it is now, and what is next for these games?
财务困境。经营彩票的州政府也患有同样的妄想。当然，这就是我们最初拥有彩票的原因，选民和政策制定者一厢情愿、愚蠢地、充满希望地相信，彩票能解决他们所有的财务问题。尽管证据确凿，甚至在其他州一次又一次失败后，这些选民和政策制定者仍然认为彩票能解决他们所有的财务问题，就像赌徒沉迷于这种信念一样，认为它对自己有效。今天，我们将与乔纳森讨论彩票是如何发展到今天这么大规模的，以及这些游戏的未来是什么？
If younger people aren't buying into the false promises of a life-changing jackpot. So Jonathan, what sparked your interest in the lottery? Yeah, I have two sort of superhero origin stories, I think, when it comes to the lottery. The first is, I'm a child of the Great Recession. You know, that was sort of the animating political moment for me as a 16, 17-year-old. So the themes of economic inequality, opportunity, and just the day-to-day stuff that people do to try to get by and to make a better life for themselves was sort of, was really salient for me
如果年轻人不再相信改变人生的头奖所带来的虚假承诺。那么乔纳森，是什么激发了你对彩票的兴趣？是的，我认为在彩票方面，我有两个所谓的“超级英雄起源故事”。第一个是，我是大衰退时期成长起来的孩子。你知道，那对我这个16、17岁的少年来说，是某种激励性的政治时刻。所以，经济不平等、机会，以及人们为了维持生计和创造更美好生活而做的日常琐事，这些主题对我来说非常突出……
going into graduate school and thinking about American history. And then of course, the real answer is that I also grew up playing board games and still played board games. And as a result, I think I'm willing to take games and play maybe more seriously than other historians might. Okay. So like, what is it about the association of board games and the lottery that, you know, makes it fascinating to you? Is it because it's a game
在进入研究生院并思考美国历史时。当然，真正的答案是，我也从小玩棋盘游戏，并且现在还在玩。因此，我认为我比其他历史学家更愿意认真对待游戏和博弈。好的。那么，棋盘游戏和彩票之间的联系，是什么让你觉得它很迷人呢？是因为它是一个……
that no one could win? What is that about it? Okay. So it's a couple things. So first of all, it's ironic that, you know, as you may know, the more serious of a board gamer you are, the less interested you are in games that are based around luck. Right? So, you know, the games that I play, you'll be shocked to hear, don't have dice, don't have like scratch off ticket or equivalents, right? But there is this old adage that I first heard from the historian Enfabian that gamblers don't read and readers don't gamble. And that there are these are two separate populations.
没人能赢的游戏吗？这到底是怎么回事？好的，有几点原因。首先，讽刺的是，正如你可能知道的那样，你越是资深的棋盘游戏玩家，就越不感兴趣那些基于运气的游戏。对吧？所以，你知道，我玩的游戏，你可能会感到震惊，没有骰子，没有刮刮乐或类似的东西，对吧？但有一个古老的格言，我最初是从历史学家恩法比安那里听到的，即“赌徒不读书，读书人不赌博”。而且这是两个独立的群体。
And she has this amazing anecdote, which she remembered during her own dissertation research in the 1980s, and she would go to the New York Public Library, and she could tell immediately in those old calling card stacks, you know, this sort of by subject, she could tell immediately where gambling started, because they were darker. The cards were darker because people have been thumbing through them, looking for guidebooks to tell them how to pick lottery numbers. So her evidence that gamblers do, in fact, read a lot. I do think the Venn diagram of people I went to graduate school and people who played lottery tickets might not be a perfect circle, but the games, the play, this desire to win.
她有一个很棒的轶事，她在80年代做博士论文研究时记得，她会去纽约公共图书馆，她能立刻从那些旧的索引卡片堆中看出赌博是从哪里开始的，因为它们颜色更深。卡片颜色更深，因为人们一直在翻阅它们，寻找教他们如何挑选彩票号码的指南书。所以她的证据表明，赌徒实际上确实读了很多书。我确实认为，我去读研究生的人群和玩彩票的人群之间的维恩图可能不是一个完美的圆，但游戏、博弈、这种获胜的渴望……
I think there are certainly some parallels between, you know, dorky board games like the ones I participated in and then the lottery lottery tickets, which as you said, are sort of very different as an activity. But could you talk a little bit about the precursors to the lottery as we know it? What were people doing that was sort of took the place of the lottery, you know, before the 70s when these really took off? Yeah, so, I mean, well, the real precursor
我认为我参与的那些书呆子气的棋盘游戏和彩票之间肯定有一些相似之处，正如你所说，彩票作为一种活动是非常不同的。但你能谈谈我们所知的彩票的前身吗？在70年代这些彩票真正兴起之前，人们在做什么来代替彩票呢？是的，我的意思是，真正的先驱……
is like the drawing of lots, you know, as described in the Bible, and this sort of acknowledgement that forces of chance can be used for distributing money, for decision making, but the actual answer to your question is they were sort of two major precursors to what we now have as the state run lottery system. The first being illegal numbers games, which were ubiquitous, particularly in urban black communities
就像《圣经》中描述的“抽签”，这种对机会力量可以用于分配金钱和决策的认可。但你问题的真正答案是，我们现在所拥有的州营彩票系统有两个主要的前身。第一个是非法数字游戏，它们无处不在，特别是在东北部和铁锈地带的城市黑人社区中……
in the Northeast and the Rust Belt, but played also by Latino gamblers, by white working class gamblers. You name it, and these are daily lotteries with three or four digits that are designed in this ingenious way that if you know where to look in the newspaper, you can find the winning number. So maybe it's the last three digits of the stock exchange, for example, for the day.
但也受到拉丁裔赌徒、白人蓝领赌徒的欢迎。随你怎么说，这些是每天开奖的三位或四位数字彩票，它们的设计非常巧妙，如果你知道在报纸上哪里看，就能找到中奖号码。例如，可能是当天证券交易所的最后三位数字。
So theoretically, before random.org exists, that's as good as source of any of a random number, right, that's publicly accessible, that can't be rigged. And these again, I can't under-evisise how popular these were in poor black communities in particular, but then all sorts of other communities all over the country too, with some organized crime involvement. Part of the appeal of numbers games, first of all is that you can pick your own numbers, which when the first state run lottery games come in,
所以从理论上讲，在random.org存在之前，那是获取随机数的好来源，对吧？它是公开可访问的，而且无法被操纵。我无法过度强调这些游戏在贫困黑人社区中有多受欢迎，但在全国各地的各种其他社区中也同样受欢迎，并伴随着一些有组织犯罪的参与。数字游戏的吸引力之一，首先是你可以自己选择号码，而当第一批州营彩票游戏出现时……
you can't do for a long time. And the real appeal is that you can play for as little as like a nickel. And you don't need, and this is sort of where the numbers games have they got started in this precursor game called policy, where it used to be like a lottery ticket in colonial America would be like the equivalent today, I'm like a luxury good. You know, it's just it's just sort of expensive, and especially in a cash pour, a gradient society, right, to put together money for a lottery ticket, you know, not not accessible to everyone. And a numbers game sort of very definitionally, very baked into the game is that you can play for a nickel, you can play for a couple pennies and get a 500, 600 fold
你很长一段时间都不能这样做。真正的吸引力在于你可以花少至五美分来玩。你不需要——这就是数字游戏起源于一种叫“政策”的前身游戏的地方——过去，殖民地时代的彩票就像今天的奢侈品。你知道，它只是有点贵，特别是在一个现金匮乏、分层的社会里，对吧？凑钱买一张彩票，你知道，并不是每个人都能负担得起。而数字游戏从定义上讲，游戏本身就内置了你可以花五美分、几便士来玩，并获得500、600倍……
return on your investment. Second part is the fact that you can pick your own numbers, which you can play in a variety of ways, you pick them, and then you have more likely than not a network. Someone you know who comes by your house every day like your milkman or the guy delivering your paper to pick up your numbers bet. Or he knows, hey, Roman plays 432 every Friday. I'm just put this down for him and assume that he's going to play in and if it hits we'll pay him out.
投资回报。第二个原因是你可以选择自己的号码，你可以通过多种方式玩，你选好号码，然后你很可能有一个人脉网络。你认识的人每天都会来你家，就像送奶工或送报员一样，来收取你的投注号码。或者他知道，嘿，罗曼每个周五都买432。我只是帮他记下，假设他会玩，如果中了，我们就给他派彩。
So it sounds quaint if you forget all the organized crime happening behind the service and the turf wars and the, you know, literal murdering that's going on to fight for control of these games in some big cities. The other equivalent for the precursor are these lottery based overseas. It's called the Irish sweepstakes. These are just sort of like basically glorified raffles that you can buy tickets for.
所以如果你忘记了幕后发生的所有有组织犯罪、地盘争夺战，以及为了争夺这些游戏的控制权而在一些大城市发生的真实谋杀案，这听起来很古雅。另一个前身是海外的彩票，叫“爱尔兰彩票”。这些基本上就是美化了的抽奖活动，你可以买票。
No one knows if anyone else. I would say no one knows if anyone actually won. Except my mom claims that the janitor of her building won and that's what allowed him to buy an apartment next to hers is because he won the Irish sweepstakes. So I guess at least one person in 1960s queens won the Irish sweepstakes at least one time. So the lottery as we know it didn't just happen. There were these few stutter steps to get to the game that we recognize today.
没人知道是否有人真的中奖了。除了我妈妈声称她那栋楼的管理员中奖了，这让他得以买下她隔壁的公寓，因为他赢了爱尔兰彩票。所以我猜至少有一个60年代皇后区的人赢过一次爱尔兰彩票。所以我们所知的彩票并不是凭空出现的。在达到我们今天所认识的游戏之前，经历了几个蹒跚的步骤。
So can you tell me about how the game design changed to get the lottery that we know now. So the New Hampshire lottery, which is the first state lottery born in 1964, comes under these conditions that it has a lot going, running against it. And there's a lot of hurdles that stand in its way. The federal government in the 1960s was not supportive of the New Hampshire lottery legalizing a state run game, and they put all these hurdles in the way. So when the New Hampshire lottery sweepstakes is starting to start up in the 1960s, part of their lottery wheel, the box that they're going to use for
那么你能告诉我游戏设计是如何改变以达到我们现在所知的彩票的吗？新罕布什尔州彩票是1964年诞生的第一个州彩票，它是在有很多不利因素的情况下诞生的。它面临着很多障碍。60年代的联邦政府并不支持新罕布什尔州彩票将州营游戏合法化，他们设置了所有这些障碍。所以当新罕布什尔州彩票在60年代开始启动时，他们彩票轮的一部分，也就是他们要用来……
the drawings and for submitting tickets, part of it is manufactured out of state. And they can't get it into New Hampshire because that would require the interstate transportation of gambling paraphernalia. So they have to, I can't remember, they either have to likehernalia. So they have to, I can't remember, either have to build it into Hampshire or they have to drive it through Canada. So it technically isn't violating interstate commerce laws. But just an example of the problems that these early state lottery's face
进行抽奖和提交彩票的盒子，部分是在州外制造的。他们无法将其运进新罕布什尔州，因为那需要跨州运输赌博用具。所以他们必须——我不记得了，他们要么必须在新罕布什尔州制造它，要么必须开车穿过加拿大。这样它在技术上就不会违反跨州商业法。但这只是早期州彩票面临的问题的一个例子……
and the hoops they had to jump through to sort of navigate the problems created for them by the federal government. And then there's also maybe more important for the actual design of the games. There's a federal excise tax on all gambling state revenue with a carve out for horse racing. So horse racing is kosher and doesn't need to be taxed, but everything else is not. So what the New Hampshire lottery does as a result is this absolutely preposterous game design where you buy
以及他们为了绕过联邦政府为他们制造的问题而必须跳过的障碍。此外，对于游戏的实际设计来说，可能更重要的是，所有赌博州收入都要缴纳联邦消费税，但赛马除外。所以赛马是合法的，不需要纳税，但其他一切都需要。因此，新罕布什尔州彩票的结果就是这种绝对荒谬的游戏设计，你买……
a lottery ticket. It's expensive, first of all. And it's not really a lottery ticket. You write your name on it, you write your address on it. So first of all, you have to declare that you're gambling at a time when gambling like isn't totally chilled, like culturally just yet. And then they do a drawing, but the drawing isn't of a name on a ticket.
一张彩票。首先，它很贵。而且它并不是真正的彩票。你在上面写上你的名字，写上你的地址。所以首先，你必须在赌博在文化上还不是完全被接受的时候声明你在赌博。然后他们进行抽奖，但抽奖不是抽彩票上的名字。
It's of a horse race. And they do a separate drawing of a number of a horse. And then they draw a name, and they tie each name to a horse in the designated horse race. So then you look up, oh, here in this 1946 race that we randomly drawn the seventh horse, one. Oh, and that, the ticket tying the 1946 race
而是抽赛马。他们对马的号码进行单独抽奖。然后他们抽一个名字，并将每个名字与指定赛马中的一匹马联系起来。然后你查一下，哦，在这场1946年的比赛中，我们随机抽出的第七匹马赢了。哦，那张将1946年比赛……
to the seventh horse, belonged to John Smith of Dover, New Hampshire. Congratulations, you won the lottery, which all of $600,000 at the time. So when talking about pennies. But this is, again, this insane game design that takes many weeks or months to actually have a drawing to get enough money.
与第七匹马联系起来的彩票，属于新罕布什尔州多佛的约翰·史密斯。恭喜你，你赢得了彩票，当时总共60万美元。所以谈论的是便士。但这又是这种疯狂的游戏设计，需要数周或数月才能进行一次抽奖以获得足够的钱。
They do some live horse racing, like sweepstakes. But as you said, it doesn't work. And it's really only starting in 1970 when the New Jersey lottery starts up and adds a weekly game that the states finally figured out. The New Jersey lottery, which starts in 1970, they really hit on the winning formula for how these early lottery are going to operate. And rather than these expensive tickets with drawings that take weeks or months, they offer
他们确实进行了一些现场赛马，比如抽奖。但正如你所说，它行不通。直到1970年新泽西州彩票启动并增加了一个每周游戏，各州才终于找到了门道。1970年启动的新泽西州彩票，他们真正找到了这些早期彩票如何运作的制胜法宝。与其使用需要数周或数月才能开奖的昂贵彩票，他们提供……
50 cent tickets for weekly games with $50,000 drawings. So pretty good sized jackpots for the time that move really, really quickly. And that will entice a lot more people to play. Cheap tickets, accessible tickets, sold everywhere. You know, the New York lottery, when they start up, they try to sell tickets in banks
50美分的每周游戏彩票，奖金为5万美元。对于那个时代来说，这是相当不错的头奖，而且开奖速度非常快。这会吸引更多的人来玩。便宜的彩票，容易获得的彩票，到处都有卖。你知道，纽约彩票在刚开始时，他们试图在银行里卖彩票……
because they think it will be secure. And then Congress is like, no f***ing way. Like, you can't do that. You can't sell lottery tickets in banks, that's insane. It's exactly opposite of the sort of ethic of savings that banks are supposed to be about. So, New Jersey is selling them in liquor stores and in bars and in barber shops. Right? Really, they get closer to the modern state lottery sales ethic and ethos that we've come to be familiar with today. So you hit on something that I find really interesting is that inside of the sort of the
因为他们认为这样会很安全。然后国会说，去你的。就像，你不能那样做。你不能在银行里卖彩票，那太疯狂了。这与银行本应代表的储蓄道德完全相反。所以，新泽西州在酒类商店、酒吧和理发店里卖彩票。对吧？他们确实更接近我们今天所熟悉的现代州彩票销售道德和精神。所以你触及了一个我觉得非常有趣的点，那就是在……
design of the game, frequency is really important. Like or immediacy, like you buy a ticket, you want it to like pay out, you know, that day or, you know, like really soon. And that's the only real way for these things to take off. Right. And that's, I mean, the real example of this is scratch tickets, right, which are introduced for the first time in Massachusetts in 1974, and then just spread like wildfire across lottery states. And then eventually to non-lottery states very, very quickly because of that immediacy that they offer. I'm truly fascinated by the way that state lottery's spread like a contact virus.
游戏设计中，频率非常重要。就像即时性，你买了一张彩票，你希望它能在那天或者很快就派彩。这是这些东西能够起飞的唯一真正途径。对吧。这就是——我的意思是，这方面的真正例子是刮刮乐，对吧，它于1974年首次在马萨诸塞州引入，然后像野火一样在彩票州蔓延。然后因为它们提供的即时性，很快就蔓延到了非彩票州。我真的对州彩票像接触性病毒一样传播的方式感到着迷。
Like if the state next to you has a lottery and your state doesn't have a lottery, you are going to get the lottery very soon. Can you describe what is going on there and the sort of psychology of that and how it infects state legislators? Yeah, there are a lot of parallels between the spread of state lotteries in this first wave. So from 1963 to 1977. And what we're seeing today with marijuana legalization, with sports betting, lots of other state policies work this way, which is that once a neighboring state legalizes something, anything, invariably people who live outside that state are going to come over and play your
就像如果隔壁州有彩票而你的州没有，你很快就会有彩票了。你能描述一下那里发生了什么，以及这种心理，以及它是如何感染州立法者的吗？是的，在第一波州彩票的传播中，有很多相似之处。从1963年到1977年。以及我们今天在大麻合法化、体育博彩方面所看到的，许多其他州政策也是这样运作的，即一旦邻州将某事合法化，任何事情，住在该州以外的人总是会过来玩你的……
lottery or play your sports betting or buy your weed. Of course, what happens in practice is that by more states legalizing, it just spreads it further, as you said, like a contact virus. So this logic, and I'm going to keep coming back to this because this is, I think, the key point here. This belief that gambling is inevitable, sort of keeps the spread going and going and keeps adding new games and keeps adding new states, but it's not inevitable. It's inevitable because states make it so by assuming
彩票，或者玩你的体育博彩，或者买你的大麻。当然，实际上发生的是，随着更多的州将其合法化，它只是进一步传播，正如你所说，像接触性病毒一样。所以这种逻辑——我会不断回到这一点，因为我认为这是这里的关键点。这种认为赌博是不可避免的信念，某种程度上保持了传播的持续，不断增加新游戏，不断增加新州，但它并不是不可避免的。它是不可避免的，因为各州通过假设……
that it is inevitable in the first place. Another thing you talk about in your book is that these August bodies take great pains to justify the lottery and sort of square it with their morals. And one of the ways they do this is by saying, well, if we have a legalized form of this, we can sort of suppress the mafia version of the lottery or the numbers version, all the illegal versions of this.
它本身就是不可避免的，从而使其成为现实。你在书中谈到的另一件事是，这些庄严的机构费尽心思为彩票辩护，并使其符合他们的道德观。他们这样做的方法之一是说，好吧，如果我们有一种合法的形式，我们就可以抑制黑手党版本的彩票或数字版本，所有这些非法版本。
Can you talk about how the lottery is sold to the public as an effective way to suppress vice and even could be virtuous because buying a lottery ticket then fills the state's coffers so it can buy good things and fund wholesome programs. Yeah, so this is like the lesson that people take away from prohibition is that there's no point in trying to suppress something that people are trying to do anyway. I mean, the prohibition of alcohol. This is happening anyway illegally. It is draining money from our police resources and our state resources. The state might as well legalize it to make money. And as you said, we could even make it a civic good.
你能谈谈彩票是如何作为一种抑制恶习的有效方式向公众兜售的，甚至可能是高尚的，因为买彩票可以填补国库，从而可以购买好东西并资助有益的计划。是的，所以这就是人们从禁酒令中吸取的教训，即试图抑制人们无论如何都要做的事情是没有意义的。我的意思是，酒精禁令。这无论如何都在非法发生。它正在耗尽我们的警察资源和州资源。州政府不如将其合法化来赚钱。正如你所说，我们甚至可以将其变成一种公民福利。
We can fund our government. We'll never have to pay taxes again because we'll have all this money that is being raised by illegal games. So that's the other, that's the other like crazy point. Is all these investigations into illegal gambling? All they do is just give people the impression that gambling is really, really lucrative and have this ironic consequence of incentivizing states
我们可以资助我们的政府。我们再也不用交税了，因为我们将拥有所有这些由非法游戏筹集的资金。所以这是另一个疯狂的点。所有这些对非法赌博的调查，它们所做的只是给人们留下赌博非常、非常有利可图的印象，并产生了一种讽刺的后果，即激励各州……
to just legalize it because they think it's gonna be super profitable. Rather than turn people off from gambling. Like imagine, every time there was a drug bust, people like, oh man, we should legalize heroin. Look at how much money all the drug dealers are making. But it doesn't happen, but that's like the equivalent of what is happening with lottery in the 60s and 70s.
将其合法化，因为他们认为这会非常有利可图。而不是让人们远离赌博。就像想象一下，每次有毒品突击搜查时，人们都说，哦天哪，我们应该把海洛因合法化。看看所有毒贩赚了多少钱。但这并没有发生，但这就像60年代和70年代彩票发生的事情的等价物。
Yeah. And so describe that when states monitored, lottery's are first being sort of proposed as a solution to the state's financial woes. What are people saying? And then what is this sort of result of it? Like their estimations for for what they're going to get out of this are really outsized and like through the roof. And then in the end, why is it that they're not paying out the way that they think they are? Right.
是的。所以描述一下当各州监控时，彩票最初被提议作为解决州财务困境的方案。人们在说什么？然后结果是什么？就像他们对从中能得到什么的估计真的非常大，而且高得离谱。最后，为什么它们没有像他们认为的那样派彩？对吧。
So this is what I think takes it from just regular politicians sort of overselling the thing that they're doing to why it's a rational, stupid, hopeful, wishful in the way that gamblers behave. In the 1960s and 70s, there's this belief, and I'm not exaggerating, this belief that a lottery is gonna singularly solve states financial problems. A New Jersey Congressman says that we can increase every state service in New Jersey four times over
所以这就是我认为将它从普通的政客过度推销他们正在做的事情，提升到为什么它是理性的、愚蠢的、充满希望的、一厢情愿的，就像赌徒的行为方式一样。在60年代和70年代，有一种信念，我没有夸张，这种信念认为彩票将单一地解决各州的财务问题。一位新泽西州国会议员说，我们可以将新泽西州的每一项州服务增加四倍……
if we make numbers games legal. The belief that we'll never have to pay taxes ever again because we have a lottery. And even this crazy cognitive dissonance, even after it doesn't work and the states have to raise taxes, this belief, hey, why are we raising taxes? Didn't we have a lottery shunned that have solved all of our financial problems? So that's sort of the panacea, the first version of the panacea. And then you say, okay, it doesn't work in the Northeast and Rust Belt.
如果我们使数字游戏合法化。这种认为我们再也不用交税的信念，因为我们有彩票。即使有这种疯狂的认知失调，即使在它不起作用且各州不得不加税之后，这种信念仍然存在：嘿，我们为什么要加税？彩票不是应该解决我们所有的财务问题吗？所以这就是某种万灵药，万灵药的第一个版本。然后你说，好吧，它在东北部和铁锈地带不起作用。
Surely these states sort of got wise and limited their expectations. And they did, but in a whole new magic bullety kind of way, where they now go in the 1980s, not thinking that the lottery is going to solve all the problems for the entire state, but oh, it will surely solve all of our education problems or it will solve, it will singly fund public parks or police services. So it's still a panesia, but we've just sort of limited ourselves. And then that panesia doesn't work, and there's still this cognitive dissonance. And then in California, for example, which uses a lottery in 1984 to raise money for education, there's this belief, even afterwards, that it's now hard to raise taxes for education,
肯定这些州变得聪明并限制了他们的期望。他们确实这样做了，但以一种全新的“魔法子弹”方式，他们在80年代进入时，不再认为彩票能解决整个州的所有问题，而是“哦，它肯定能解决我们所有的教育问题”，或者它将单一地资助公园或警察服务。所以它仍然是一种万灵药，我们只是限制了自己。然后那种万灵药不起作用，仍然存在这种认知失调。然后在加利福尼亚州，例如，它在1984年利用彩票为教育筹集资金，即使在那之后，人们仍然认为现在很难为教育加税……
because people think that the lottery is funding education, and that we don't need any more money to pay for schools. And of course, that doesn't work. It's like 2% of the California education budget. But then come the 90s, still this cognitive dissonance. Oh, if we have a lottery, it's like that other rest of the development line. Like it fails for everybody else, but surely it'll work for us.
因为人们认为彩票正在资助教育，我们不需要更多的钱来支付学校费用。当然，这不起作用。它大约只占加州教育预算的2%。但到了90年代，仍然存在这种认知失调。哦，如果我们有彩票，就像那条发展线的其余部分一样。它对别人失败了，但肯定会对我们有效。
Like, oh, it will still solve all of our problems, but we'll just reduce the problems a little bit more that they're gonna solve. Oh, in Georgia and other states in particular, it's we don't have enough students going to college, specifically in state colleges and universities. So we'll just use our lottery money to pay for that. So that, okay, finally it works.
就像，哦，它仍然会解决我们所有的问题，但我们只是减少了它们要解决的问题。哦，在佐治亚州和其他州，特别是我们没有足够的学生上大学，特别是在州立学院和大学。所以我们将用我们的彩票钱来支付。所以，好吧，终于它起作用了。
First of all, finally the lottery actually sort of fulfills its mandate and does what they say it's going to do, but this belief over and over again, it's gonna solve problem X and it doesn't solve problem X. Oh, okay, but belief over and over again, it's going to solve problem X and then it doesn't solve problem X. Oh, okay, but we'll definitely solve problem Y. Oh, it doesn't solve problem Y. Oh, it'll maybe solve this other problem instead.
首先，终于彩票实际上履行了它的使命，做了他们说它会做的事情，但这种信念一次又一次地出现，它会解决问题X，但它没有解决问题X。哦，好吧，但信念一次又一次地出现，它会解决问题X，然后它没有解决问题X。哦，好吧，但我们肯定会解决问题Y。哦，它没有解决问题Y。哦，它也许会解决其他问题。
They can't just say, hey, the lottery will be nice. It'll raise 2% of state revenue. You know, they can't do that. They have to sort of have this wing in a prayer that it's going to be a jackpot, you know, pun intended for the state. Right, and 2% of state revenue isn't nearly enough to fund all the services that they're promising.
他们不能只是说，嘿，彩票会很好。它将筹集2%的州收入。你知道，他们不能那样做。他们必须有一种“祈祷”的心态，认为它会是一个头奖，（双关语）对州政府来说。对，而2%的州收入远不足以资助他们承诺的所有服务。
That's really interesting. So, could you describe what are the typical state-lotto games and how they work and what customer base each of the games are appealing to? If we're thinking about all 45 lottery states, because there are some games that are only played in some states, some games and others. There are really three big games that lottery is rely on. The first and the one that needs to be mentioned first are scratch tickets, which account of first, about a 60 to 65% of total annual lottery sales. And so there are a couple of different players for this. What we've seen recently in scratch tickets isickets is what I would call the sort of jack podification of the games, where now you're by scratch tickets that can cost as much as $100 in Texas.
这真的很有趣。那么，你能描述一下典型的州彩票游戏是什么，它们是如何运作的，以及每种游戏吸引的是什么客户群吗？如果我们考虑所有45个彩票州，因为有些游戏只在某些州玩，有些游戏在其他州玩。彩票依赖的游戏确实有三大类。第一类，也是首先需要提到的，是刮刮乐，它占了年度彩票总销售额的60%到65%。所以这有几个不同的玩家。我们在刮刮乐中最近看到的是……我称之为游戏的“头奖化”，现在你买的刮刮乐在德克萨斯州可能要花100美元。
And we've gone from, they offered you to sort of distance chance at a big prize, but you're really playing for sort of the medium prize to now there are scratch tickets that offer a $15 million jackpot, sort of meant a rival, the lotto rollover powerball mega-million type games. What's cool about scratch tickets is the prize curve is shaped like a U, if you imagine, the letter U. There are a lot of prizes concentrated at the very, very beginning. So free tickets, $2 back, $5 back, and then there's a big gap, and then there's prizes at the very top, 20,000, 50,000, 100,000 more, on the assumption that no one's getting out of bed
我们已经从它们提供给你一个大奖的遥远机会，但你实际上是在玩中等奖，变成了现在有提供1500万美元头奖的刮刮乐，旨在与乐透滚存、强力球、超级百万类型的游戏竞争。刮刮乐很酷的地方在于奖金曲线呈U型，如果你想象一下字母U。在最开始集中了很多奖项。所以免费彩票、返还2美元、5美元，然后有一个很大的差距，然后在最顶端有奖项，2万、5万、10万更多，假设没有人会为了1000美元而起床……
for a thousand dollars, and on the assumption that if you win five, 10, 20 dollars, you'll probably put that back into more tickets. So you can play for your jackpot, and you can sort of keep playing, keep playing, keep playing, because you put 20 dollars in, you get 10 back, you put 10 in, you get seven back, you put seven in, you get, you know, et cetera.
并假设如果你赢了5、10、20美元，你可能会把钱投入到更多的彩票中。所以你可以为你的头奖而玩，你可以一直玩、一直玩、一直玩，因为你投入了20美元，拿回了10美元，你投入了10美元，拿回了7美元，你投入了7美元，你拿回了，你知道，等等。
All of a sudden you spent $40 on lottery tickets and you even have $40 to begin with. That's sort of the bread and butter for lottery commissions. As a result, so many types of players for those games, they are one of the most regressive lottery games, meaning the poor players play them more often, they spend a higher percentage of their money on them to relative to other games. The other sort of major regressive game, in particular,
突然之间你花了40美元买彩票，而你甚至一开始只有40美元。这就是彩票委员会的“面包和黄油”。因此，这些游戏有这么多类型的玩家，它们是最具累退性的彩票游戏之一，意味着贫穷的玩家玩得更频繁，他们花在这些游戏上的钱占他们收入的比例比其他游戏更高。另一种主要的累退游戏，特别是……
are numbers games, which we've already covered, which remain actually particularly and disproportionately popular among black gamblers. And again, sort of have this historical roots in the black community that sort of carry them forward to today. So the state, just in the mid-1970s, just usurped these illegal games and these are now basically the they haven't changed the design. The design that was created in 1924 by a black immigrant from the Dutch West Indies named Casper Holstein. They don't use like the newspaper anymore to pick the winning number, but it's the same exact game design now just run by your state government. So eventually, rather than having, or provide the numbers, they have that big cage
是数字游戏，我们已经讨论过了，它们实际上在黑人赌徒中仍然特别且不成比例地受欢迎。而且再次，在黑人社区中有这种历史根源，一直延续到今天。所以州政府在70年代中期，只是篡夺了这些非法游戏，现在它们基本上是——他们没有改变设计。这个设计是由一位来自荷属西印度群岛的黑人移民卡斯珀·霍尔斯坦在1924年创造的。他们不再像以前那样使用报纸来挑选中奖号码，但现在完全是同样的游戏设计，只是由你的州政府经营。所以最终，与其拥有，或者提供号码，他们有那个大笼子……
that they roll in the little balls and they pick out random numbers. I used to watch it on TV. Yes, they have lottery balls in most states. Maryland is now going digital and there's a whole like crisis of faith. People I talked to in my book already think the lottery's rigged, right?
他们把小球滚进去，然后挑出随机号码。我过去常在电视上看到它。是的，大多数州都有彩票球。马里兰州现在正在数字化，这引发了整个信仰危机。我在书中采访的人已经认为彩票被操纵了，对吧？
All these people who have lost faith in the system, they play anyway because they don't see any other chance. And now, doing away from lottery balls, I think for more people is just gonna be even one more. Right, all these people who have lost faith in the system, they play anyway because they don't see any other chance. And now, doing away from lottery balls, I think for more people, it's just going to be even one more. Like, all right, they already picked numbers. This is what the gangsters used to do all the time, but when they could get away with it, was pick numbers that they knew no one had played.
所有这些对系统失去信心的人，他们还是玩，因为他们看不到任何其他机会。现在，放弃彩票球，我认为对更多人来说只是又多了一个……对，所有这些对系统失去信心的人，他们还是玩，因为他们看不到任何其他机会。现在，放弃彩票球，我认为对更多人来说，这只是又多了一个。就像，好吧，他们已经选好了号码。这就是黑帮过去常做的事情，但当他们能逃脱惩罚时，就是挑选他们知道没人买的号码。
They say, oh, tons of people have played 163 today. We shouldn't let that be the winning number. It should be 721, which only a couple of people played, so we're not going to lose as much money if that comes up. So there's all these things that say a lot of we do that. And then what are their jackpots like? These games are not jackpot based games. These are fixed payout games. Describe the difference between a jackpot and a fixed payout. Sure. So there's a term called paramutual betting. So this is this refers to Powerball Megan Millions, which is my last category that I want to get into, which is where the jackpot is
他们说，哦，今天有很多人买了163。我们不应该让它成为中奖号码。应该是721，只有几个人买了，所以如果那个号码出来，我们不会损失那么多钱。所以州彩票也会做所有这些事情。那么他们的头奖是什么样的？这些游戏不是基于头奖的游戏。这些是固定派彩游戏。描述一下头奖和固定派彩之间的区别。当然。有一个术语叫“平分彩金投注”。所以这指的是强力球和超级百万，这是我想进入的最后一个类别，即头奖……
varies depending on the amount of that people bet. Whereas numbers games is fixed payout in that $1, if you win, will net you a $400, $500 payout? Doesn't matter how many other people bet on that number, a winning number pays out at a certain amount every time for every dollar that you spend on it. Got it. Got it. Right. And then the last one, so 13, 15% of total annual lottery sales are Lotto games, L-O-T-T-O. Most familiar are Powerball and Mega Millions, which are the multi-state iterations of Lotto games, but a lot of states, especially populist states
取决于人们投注的金额。而数字游戏是固定派彩，即1美元，如果你赢了，将获得400、500美元的派彩？不管有多少其他人投注那个号码，中奖号码每次都会为你投入的每一美元支付一定金额。明白了。明白了。对。然后最后一个，所以年度彩票总销售额的13%到15%是乐透游戏，L-O-T-T-O。最熟悉的是强力球和超级百万，它们是乐透游戏的多州迭代，但很多州，特别是人口众多的州……
like California, also have their own Lotto games that are, you know, the tickets are only playable in California, don't have as big prizes, but also, as a know, the tickets are only playable in California. Don't have as big prizes, but also as a result, don't have quite as long odds. Right. So the jackpot is determined by the number of people buying in, which is what leads to these huge jackpots. But that wasn't always the case. And this was this innovation that came a little bit later. Can you describe the lotto and how that functions? Sure. Well, a lotto has its roots in 15th century Italy,
像加利福尼亚州，也有他们自己的乐透游戏，你知道，彩票只能在加利福尼亚州玩，没有那么大的奖金，但也因此，赔率也没有那么长。对。所以头奖是由购买的人数决定的，这就是导致这些巨额头奖的原因。但这并不总是这样。这是后来才出现的创新。你能描述一下乐透以及它是如何运作的吗？当然。嗯，乐透起源于15世纪的意大利……
but I'm not gonna get into that. But it's exactly as you described, first introduced in Massachusetts in 1978, and then in New York, and New York is the one that really figures out the formula in 1978. The point of the game is there is a predetermined share of every ticket that goes specifically to the top prize.
但我不会深入讨论那个。但它正如你所描述的那样，1978年首次在马萨诸塞州引入，然后在纽约，纽约是1978年真正弄清楚公式的地方。游戏的重点是，每张彩票中有一个预定的份额专门用于最高奖项。
So for every dollar spent on lot of tickets, I'm making up these numbers. 50% goes to the top prize, 25% goes to the secondary prizes, and then 25% goes to the state or something. So the more people bet, the bigger the jackpot will get. It did not mean to rhyme. But you do importantly have a starting prize. So right now, Powerball Mega Millions started at 20 million, even if no one plays. And the appeal of these games is as weeks, months go on,
所以对于花在乐透彩票上的每一美元，我编造这些数字。50%用于最高奖项，25%用于二级奖项，然后25%用于州政府或其他什么。所以投注的人越多，头奖就会越大。我不是故意要押韵的。但你确实有一个重要的起始奖金。所以现在，强力球和超级百万即使没人玩，也从2000万开始。这些游戏的吸引力在于随着几周、几个月的过去……
and no one wins, but people keep buying tickets, the prize can keep going up. And in the 1980s, states did away with prize caps. So now, theoretically, prizes can go forever. And as we speak, there's a $1.3 billion mega-million strong tonight that I'm probably not going to win. And two months ago, there was a $2.3 billion
没人中奖，但人们继续买票，奖金可以不断增加。在80年代，各州取消了奖金上限。所以现在，从理论上讲，奖金可以永远增加。就在我们说话的时候，今晚有一个13亿美元的超级百万大奖，我可能不会赢。两个月前，有一个23亿美元的……
powerball jackpot that was the largest in US history. Because basically people didn't get lucky. Like no one got lucky for a couple of months and that's what let the prizes keep growing. And people kept throwing money at it, hoping to win, and the odds are one in 302 million, and you're not going to win, and eventually someone does. And in the case of the Powerball, you've got these growing jackpots that people aren't winning from week to week, and you're choosing from a set of numbers for your chance to win.
强力球头奖，是美国历史上最大的。因为基本上人们没有那么幸运。就像几个月来没有人走运，这就是让奖金不断增长的原因。人们不断地往里面投钱，希望能赢，赔率是3.02亿分之一，你不会赢，最终有人会赢。在强力球的情况下，你有这些不断增长的头奖，人们每周都没有中奖，你正在从一组数字中选择你的中奖机会。
But we get the addition of one extra Powerball number, which might not seem like a big deal, but it really changes the odds drastically. Can you describe that from a design perspective? What is that doing? Yeah. So over time, over the last few decades, basically state lottery commissions have realized that people don't care about the odds of winning. They just care about how big the jackpots are.
但我们增加了一个额外的强力球号码，这看起来可能不是什么大不了的事，但它确实极大地改变了赔率。你能从设计的角度描述一下吗？那是在做什么？是的。所以随着时间的推移，在过去的几十年里，基本上州彩票委员会已经意识到人们并不关心获胜的赔率。他们只关心头奖有多大。
So they've made the games harder and harder to win. Starting the late 80s, early 90s, with the introduction of, it was then called Laudo America, ultimately called Powerball. This game where in addition to having to pick, I think it was originally five numbers from a field ranging from one through 45, you also had to pick a sixth number.
因此，他们让中奖变得越来越难。从80年代末、90年代初开始，随着当时被称为“美国乐透”（Laudo America），最终演变为“强力球”（Powerball）的彩票引入，这款游戏除了要求你从1到45的数字区间内选择（我记得最初是五个数字），还要求你选择第六个数字。
I think at the time was ranging between one and 26 that doesn't seem that hard, but on paper makes the odds even that much more preposterous and that much harder to hit. What you see a lot, and you see this actually both with scratch tickets and with lot of games is states sort of tricking your brain
我记得当时那个数字是在1到26之间，这看起来并不难，但在纸面上，这让中奖概率变得更加荒谬，也更难中奖。你经常会看到，实际上在刮刮乐和许多彩票游戏中，各州都在某种程度上欺骗你的大脑，
and this fostering this belief that, oh, the winning numbers had a 55 and my ticket had a 56. So I was supposed to feel as if I was only one number away. When, of course, that has no bearing on like what lottery ball was randomly drawn in the drawing. The real bad one with this is scratch tickets, where if your winning number, let's say, is a 13 or a three, the numbers that you scratch might be like a two's say, is a 13 or a three, the numbers
并助长了一种信念，即“哦，中奖号码里有个55，而我的彩票上有个56”。所以我本该觉得我只差一个数字就中奖了。当然，这与摇奖机随机摇出的号码毫无关系。最糟糕的是刮刮乐，如果你的中奖号码是13或3，你刮开的数字可能是2，也就是离3只差一个数字。所以你会觉得，哦，我太接近了。或者可能是个8，刚刮开时看起来像个3。所以，这些被称为“心脏骤停”彩票。这些彩票旨在让你瞬间以为自己中奖了，结果却发现自己输了，并想通过下一张彩票来追回损失。当你买彩票时，随机选号的出现是如何改变游戏的？有一个非常有趣的方式，它们缩短了排队时间，因为你不需要……你以前得，想象一下，这相当于强力球，但只在你所在的州。
that you scratch might be like a two, which is one number away from a three. So you're like, oh, I'm so close. Or might be an eight, which is like when you first scratch it might look like a three. So it's, they're called heart stoppers. Tickets that are meant to make you think for a moment that you won, only to realize that you lost and you want to chase that win with another ticket. How did the advent of random number picking when you buy a ticket change the game? In one really funny way, they made the lines shorter because you didn't have to, you used to like, imagine it's the equivalent of Powerball, but it's only in your state.
所以那是1985年的纽约。每个人都在排队等待那创纪录的4000万美元大奖。这是美国历史上最大的奖金。每家零售店门口都排起了长队，因为每个人都在排队买彩票，但所有这些人，你知道，富人、中产阶级，都不知道怎么填写彩票单，他们必须自己选号，但纽约州当时还没有引入“快速选号”（QuickPick），也就是打印一张随机彩票。所以这是一种奇怪而有趣的方式。我读过一位1990年伊利诺伊州彩票专员提出的一个有趣的理论，即“快速选号”的出现
So it's New York in 1985. Everyone's waiting in line for this record-breaking $40 million jackpot. It's the largest in American history. And they're lines out the door of every retailer because everyone's waiting in line to buy tickets, but all these people, you know, rich, middle-class people don't know how to fill out the lottery slip and they have to pick their own numbers, but New York State has not yet introduced QuickPick, which is the printing of a random ticket. So that's one sort of weird funny way. An interesting theory I read from an Illinois lottery commissioner from 1990 is that the advent of quick pick
使得彩票奖金不太可能出现滚存。当人们必须自己选号时，猜猜他们选什么数字？特别是在1到31之间，因为那是日期、生日等等。一旦有了随机打印的彩票，每次开奖都会覆盖更广泛的数字范围，因为不再……过去每个人都只在1到31之间选号，从理论上讲，这会使奖金滚存的可能性降低，因为现在有人拿着一张包含
made it less likely that lottery prizes would roll over. When people had to pick their own numbers, guess what numbers they picked, ranging specifically between one and 31 because those are dates, birthdays, etc. Once there's a random printing of tickets, a wider range of numbers is covered for every drawing, because not... It used to be just everyone's playing between numbers between one and 31, and that would make it theoretically less likely that the prize would roll over, because someone now has a ticket with numbers
50多和60多数字的彩票，而他们以前绝不会选这些数字。所以这是一个很酷的理论，它被呈现为一种非常、非常、非常显而易见的事实。我不知道它有多真实。我的意思是，在这一点上，我认为很多人都玩快速选号，但确实如此。而且这也让我的父亲愿意玩，因为他不想去弄清楚怎么填写彩票单，你懂我的意思吗？但他会直接给那个人两美元，并期待换回一张彩票。
in the 50s and 60s that they never would have picked before. So it's a cool theory that's very, very, very, presented visible kind of, kind of, kind of fact. I don't know how true it is. I mean, at this point, I think a lot of people play quick, but yeah. And then it also makes it like so that my dad will play because he's not going to like figure out how to fill out the lottery slip, you know what I mean? But he will like just hand two dollars to the guy and expect a lottery ticket
是的，确实如此。是的，这真的很有趣，因为它奏效了，而且，我不知道，这取决于你是想提高奖金池还是想筹集资金。拥有“快速选号”让过程更顺畅，但也确实增加了人们中奖的可能性，因为他们会选到那些数字。到目前为止，他们一直做得很好，并获得了大奖。你能谈谈游戏设计与中奖概率之间的关系吗？看起来日常的小额奖金游戏的中奖概率是你能够理解的。
in return. Yeah, it does. Yeah, that's really interesting because it works and sort of, I don't know, it depends from the point of view of trying to raise jackpots or trying to raise money. It makes it more frictionless to have the quick pick, but it also makes it more likely that, you know, people would get a prize because they would pick numbers. That would be so far they've been doing just fine and getting big prizes. Can you talk about how the games are designed in relation to the odds? It seems like the daily smaller jackpot games have odds of winning that you can kind of wrap your head around.
比如有三个数字，从1到9。选出一个中奖者似乎相对容易，这就是为什么花一美元买一个小奖金感觉很合理。但当奖金变得非常巨大，比如像“超级百万”（Mega Millions）那样时，中奖概率是微乎其微的，这并不重要，因为大奖的潜在收益太诱人了，以至于它直接让我们的大脑短路了。我的理解对吗？不，不，不，是的，不，你说到点子上了。你提到了几件事。
There's like three numbers, one through nine. It seems almost like comparatively easy to pick a winner And that's why you know paying a buck for a small jackpot feels rational But when the jackpot is you know something like the mega-millions it gets so huge Like it doesn't matter if the odds are picking the winning number is Inventessively small like the upside of the big jackpot is so overwhelming That it just kind of short circuits our brains I mean do I have that right? No, no, no, yeah, no, you're hitting on it. You're hitting on a couple things
所以这些游戏有非常不同的玩家群体，你是对的，处于收入最低五分位的人群，实际上并没有不成比例地去玩彩票，因为他们没有多少可支配收入花在彩票上。但当他们玩的时候，正如你所说，他们不会花2美元去买一张中奖概率为3.02亿分之一的“超级百万”彩票来博取巨额奖金。他们是在玩数字游戏，试图把1美元变成400美元，或者买一张便宜的刮刮乐，
So these games have very different player bases and you're right folks at the very bottom income quintile Right don't actually play the lottery all that disproportionately because they don't have a lot of disposable income to spend on lottery tickets But when they do play, they're not, to exactly your point, they're not gonna invest $2 in a mega millions ticket with a one in 302 million odds of a giant jackpot. They are playing a numbers game trying to turn $1 into $400, or buying a cheap scratch ticket,
希望能中那个100美元、10万美元的奖金。你知道，他们不是为了大奖而玩。他们只是为了度过这一天。是下一个层级，收入分配中大约21%到60%的那部分人，他们有可支配收入来玩，也许觉得他们在生活中没有太多机会
hoping to, they're actually the ones hoping for that $100, $100,000 payout. You know, they're not, they're not playing for a jackpot. They're just playing to get through the day. It's that next level up, that next group up, you know, 21st to 60th roughly of the income distribution who have disposable income to play, maybe perceive that they don't have a lot of opportunities
去致富，或者去摆脱困境，或者去实现美国梦，无论你怎么称呼它，他们是那些愿意花两美元去博取13亿分之一的渺茫机会的人。然后另一个因素是，人们无法分辨四百万分之一的中奖概率、四千万分之一的中奖概率或四亿分之一的中奖概率之间的区别，但他们绝对能分辨出四百万美元、四千万美元或四亿美元奖金之间的区别。所以四百万分之一的中奖概率
in their life to get rich or to get out or to for the American dream or whatever you want to call it and they're the ones who are willing to spend two dollars on the distant distant distant odds of 1.3 billion. And then the other you know factor here, people can't tell the difference between one in four million odds of winning, one in 40 million odds of winning or one in 400 million odds of winning, or one in 400 million odds of winning, but they sure as hell can tell the difference between a four million dollar, 40 million or 400 million dollar jackpot. So one in four million odds of winning
已经感觉非常遥远了，以至于它和四亿分之一没什么两样，而且你还能为了更多的钱去玩。是的。当数字变得如此巨大时，它会使我们的大脑短路，因为这就像，为什么不呢？你知道，我听说奖金涨到了1.3亿美元。当数字变得如此巨大时，就像为什么不呢？当我们回来时，我们将讨论如果人们不再购买彩票，彩票的未来会是什么样子。
already feels so distant that they might as well be one in 400 and then you get to play for a lot more money. Yeah. It's kind of short circuits or brain when the number gets so big, because it's like, why not? You know, I heard the jackpot's up to $130 million. number gets so big because it's like why not? When we come back, we'll talk about what the future of the lottery looks like if people
在Jonathan D. Cohen之后，还有更多内容。所以在一个像美国这样的国家，你知道，无论对错，它通过功绩来定义自己，即好运降临在努力工作的人身上，彩票是如何融入这种自我神话的呢？是的，所以有一种信念，即我们生活在一个精英管理社会，好人会有好报，特别是如果你努力工作，好事情就会发生，
are no longer buying in. More with Jonathan D. Cohen after this. So in a country like the U.S., which, you know, rightly or wrongly defines itself through, you know, merit, the idea that, you idea that good things come to people who work hard, how does the lot of fit in with that sort of self-mythology? Yeah, so there's this belief that we live in a meritocracy where good things happen to good people and specifically good things happen if you work hard,
努力工作总会有回报。如果你仔细想想，那个理论并没有给偶然性留下太多空间。它在某种程度上排除了概率。它说，不，努力工作和回报与成功之间有一条直线。赌博绝对是对这种观念的嘲弄。它真正说的是，嘿，你知道，世界是完全随机的，那些致富的人并不是因为他们做错了什么，你知道，只是因为他们某天选对了数字。所以我认为那个关于精英管理社会的故事是我们告诉自己的故事，但有很多证据表明，在这个故事之下，有很多赌博行为正在发生，而且
working hard always pays off. And that theory, if you think about it, doesn't leave a lot of room for chance. It sort of cuts out, it cuts out probability. It says, no, there's a straight line between hard work and payoff and success. Gambling absolutely spits in the face of that. And really says, hey, you know, the world is totally random and people who get rich through no fault of their own, you know, because they picked the numbers one day. So I think that that that story of a merictitious society is the one we tell ourselves, but there's a lot of evidence that underneath that story, there's a lot of gambling going on and that
很多人，特别是少数族裔，或者那些被排除在传统主流经济之外的人，长期以来一直转向靠运气来追求他们所看到的美国梦，而这种梦在传统经济中对他们来说是不可及的。那么宗教呢？彩票是如何与宗教相契合的？是的，所以也许并非巧合，1970年代州彩票的兴起，与“繁荣福音”的兴起以及这种功利主义金钱的注入，或者一位学者所称的“奇迹般的精英管理”相吻合。
a lot of people, particularly people of color, or those who have been excluded from the traditional mainstream economy, have long turned to the luck of the draw for the American dream that they saw, but wasn't available to them through the traditional economy. And what about religion? How does the lottery fit in with that? Yeah, so maybe not coincidentally, around the rise of state lottery in the 1970s, coincides with the rise of the prosperity gospel and this sort of inflection of merititious money or what one scholar calls him a miraculous meritocracy.
这种信念是，如果你值得，奇迹就会为你发生，特别是如果你向教会捐款、如果你祈祷、如果你做某某事，经济奇迹就会为你发生。而彩票作为偶然性的典型载体，与此相契合。突然之间，我们在1970年代，
This belief that if you're deserving, miracles will happen for you, specifically financial miracles will happen for you if you give to the church, if you pray, if you do XYZ. And lottery fits in with that as a the quintessential vehicle of chance. All of a sudden, we get in the 1970s,
所有这些中奖的彩票玩家，与其将其视为偶然性的载体，不如说，“哦不，上帝给了我钱。哦，我理应得到我的钱。”他们觉得他们理应富有，但事实并非如此，而突然之间他们变得富有，如果你不愿意将你的大奖归因于随机概率，那么只有一种解释，那就是
all these lottery players who win the lottery, who rather than see it as a vehicle of chance, oh no, God gave me my money. Oh, I deserve to, I deserve my money. This is, they felt they deserved to be rich, but weren't, and all of a sudden they are, and if you're not willing to ascribe your jackpot to random probability, there's sort of only one explanation in that is
去假设上帝是给你钱的那个人。所以在你的书中，你提到年轻一代玩彩票的意愿要低得多，你知道这是为什么吗？这对美国彩票的未来意味着什么？是的，所以只有一些轶事证据，但现有的证据表明，Z世代，实际上还有千禧一代，对彩票的兴趣不如老一代。我对此的个人理论是，现在有
to look, look, have in words to, to, to assume that God is the one who gave you your money. So when your book you mention that younger generations are much less inclined to play the lottery, do you know why that is and, and what that means for the future of lottery and the US? and what that means for the future of lottery and the US. Yeah, well, so there's only sort of anecdotal evidence, but the evidence that exists is that Gen Z and actually millennials too are not as interested in lottery tickets as older generations. My sort of personal pet theory for this is that there are
无数种获得赌博快感的好方法，加密货币、Robinhood、某些州的体育博彩。特别是，这些游戏让你觉得自己很聪明。如果你赢了，那不仅仅是靠运气，对吧？不仅仅是完全随机的偶然。如果你赢了，那是因为，哦，你看出休斯顿火箭队的盘口低了三分，你利用了它，因为你是个天才。
tons of great ways to get a gambling fix nowadays, crypto, Robinhood, sports betting in some states. And in particular, those games let you feel smart. If you win, it's not just luck of the draw, right? It's not just like totally random chance. It is like if you win, it's because, oh, you saw that that Houston Rockets line was three points too low and you took advantage of it because you're a genius.
而且有同样多的无摩擦投注，甚至更无摩擦，你知道，因为在线访问太方便了。所以他们做着同样的事情，我实际上在GameStop事件期间从WallStreetBets Reddit页面上找到了一个很棒的引语，他基本上是，你可以直接删掉“GameStop”这个词，
And there's just as much sort of frictionless betting, even more so frictionless, you know, because it's so accessible online. So they're doing the same thing and they actually found a great quote from someone on the Wall Street Betts Reddit page during the whole GameStop thing where he's basically, you could just like cut out the word GameStop
换成“彩票”，听起来就像一个彩票玩家。就像这是我唯一的机会。这是我致富的最佳方式，然后把所有的鸡蛋放在一个篮子里，真正成就一番事业。我知道中奖概率可能很低，我知道在纸面上这可能是一项愚蠢的金融投资，但我还是要这么做。我认为他们再次从彩票玩家那里得到了同样的东西。但他们只是以不同的方式找到了它。而且这，我相信，对许多专员来说是一个非常、非常令人担忧的问题，
and put in the word lottery tickets and it sounds exactly like a lottery player. Like this is my only chance. This is my best way to sort of like get get rich and then put all put all my eggs in a basket and really make something of myself. And I know that the odds might be long and I know that it might be a stupid financial investment on paper but I'm going to do it. And I think again they're really getting the same thing the lottery players get out of it. But they're just finding it in different ways. And this is I'm sure do it. And I think, again, they're really getting the same thing the lottery players get out of it, but they're just finding it in different ways. And this is, I'm sure an issue of much, much consternation for a lot of commissioners
他们不希望游戏消失，并希望吸引这些年轻一代。我的意思是，你认为这些彩票控制年轻玩家的方式是让奖金变得如此巨大吗？是的。这绝对有帮助，因为这能吸引人们进门。
who don't want the games to fade away and who wanna get these younger generations hooked. I mean, do you think that the way that these lottery's controlling younger players is by making the jackpot so big? Yeah. That definitely helps because what that does is it gets people through the door.
一旦他们进门，你就有多种方式留住他们。也许你让他们沉迷于自己的数字，他们觉得必须玩下去。所以你玩自己的数字。Roman每天都下注。好吧，现在他觉得，好吧，我玩彩票玩得很开心。我要停下来。
And once they're in the door, you have them in a bunch of ways. Maybe you get them hooked on their own numbers and they feel like they have to play. So you play your own numbers. Roman places numbers every day for a month. Okay, now he's like, all right, I've had fun playing the lottery. I'm gonna stop.
但随后你得到了一种叫做“损失厌恶”的东西，Roman想停下来，但他实际上不想停下来，因为如果彩票中了他选的数字，他会因为自己没玩而感到非常愤怒。所以他避免停下来不是因为他想玩，而是因为他不想错过。所以这就是大奖游戏，你知道，它们看起来很温和，但实际上是人们进门的入门毒品。所以这肯定会有所帮助。
But then what you get is something called for a great aversion where Roman wants to stop, but he actually doesn't want to stop because if the lottery hit on his numbers, he would feel so angry that he didn't play. So he avoids not because he wants to play, but because he doesn't want to not play. So that's how the big jackpot games, you know, they seem benign, but it's actually sort of a gateway drug for people to get in the door. So that certainly will help.
而且彩票在这些大奖期间获得的媒体关注在某种程度上是有害的。我认为他们真正追求的是试图转向无现金购票。有些州，马萨诸塞州，直到最近还是我的州，你只能用现金买票。然后在线，你知道，通过应用程序等，才是真正的目标。好吧。所以Jonathan，问题来了。
And the media attention that Lotteries get during those checkbots is harmful in that way. I think the real way they're going after them is trying to transfer to cashless ticket sales. Some states, Massachusetts, my help state until very recently, you'd only buy tickets and cash. And then online, you know, through apps and stuff is the real targeting. All right. So Jonathan, here's the question. All right. and then online, you know, through apps and stuff is the real targeting. All right, so Jonathan, here's the question.
好吧。了解你所知道的一切，你认为彩票是坏事吗？因为我觉得它们有点坏。我实际上认为如果你在1970年问我，彩票是坏事吗，我会说不。它们实际上在净值上可能是好的，因为当时到处都是赌博。
All right. Knowing everything you know, do you think longaries are bad? Because I think they're kind of bad. I actually think if you had asked me in 1970, like, are lottery's bad, I would've said no. They're actually probably on net good because there's all this gambling.
无论如何，确实到处都在发生赌博。它在某些情况下确实助长了有组织犯罪。我认为彩票，你知道，在当时是一个很好的创新。我认为现在，你知道，2023年，它们显然弊大于利，不应该以目前的形式和目前的迭代存在于现代美国社会中。
There really was all this gambling happening anyway. It really is feeding into, in some cases, organized crime. I think Lotteries, you know, at the time were a good innovation. I think now, you know, 2023, they are clearly doing more harm than good and should not exist in their current form and their current iteration in the modern American society.
在这段时间里，有哪些经验事实的积累让你认为彩票现在是坏事？是的。我会从净值的角度，你知道，给予应有的肯定。据我估计，在过去的五十多年里，彩票为各州筹集了2520亿美元，这，你知道，很好，对他们来说很好。当然，问题是这笔钱的成本，有几个。
What is the accumulation of empirical facts over that time that make you think that lotteries are bad now? Yeah. I'll do it in the sort of net, you know, give credit to, you know, give credit where they do. Lotteries have, by my estimation, raise, I think, $252 billion for states over the course of five plus decades, which, you know, great, good for them. The question, of course, is the cost of that money, and there are a couple.
首先，当然是它们具有累退性。如果有人今天引入一种具有彩票的累退性和分配方式的税收，人们会翻白眼，它永远不会通过，仅仅是因为知道谁会为这种税买单。当然，这是自愿的，但这就是他们证明其合理性的方式。所以这是一个主要影响。另一个是彩票扭曲了美国人
First of all, of course, is the fact that they are regressive. And if someone were to introduce a tax today with the regressivity and the distribution of lotteries, people would roll their eyes, it would never get past just because of knowing who is going to buy into this tax. Of course, it's voluntary, but that's the way they justify it. So that's one major effect. Another is the ways that lotteries have warped Americans
对社会流动性的信念。而且它们，我引用了一位记者的话，她称之为“盲目的灯塔”，对于那些将彩票视为他们摆脱困境的最后、最好、唯一机会的人来说。另一个很难量化的是它们扭曲了美国人对财富、对普遍奢华的信念。自1980年代、1990年代以来，随着对财富的推崇和名人CEO的崛起，我认为彩票帮助人们接受了不平等，假设也许有一天他们也会致富，而且他们不想在成为亿万富翁时支付
beliefs about social mobility. And they have, I quote, one journalist who calls, she calls it a blinding beacon for people who are sort of see the lottery as their last best only chance for, for a way out. Another one that is really hard to quantify is just the way they've warped Americans' belief in wealth, in opulence in general. And since the 1980s, this 1990s, with the valorization of wealth and the rise of the celebrity CEO, the lotteries have helped people, I think, become okay with inequality on the assumption that maybe they're going to get rich one day too, and they don't want to have to pay
遗产税。同样，真的很难量化。关于累退性的第一点是最大的。但这就是导致我相信彩票是坏事的原因。我进入彩票话题时并没有什么偏见。我不是彩票赢家或输家。我父母成长过程中也没玩过。但这就是我，我的结论，看着关于这个问题的证据净值。
estate taxes either when not if they become a billionaire. Again, really hard to quantify. That first one about the regressivity is the big one. But that's what leads me to believe on that lottery's a bad. I didn't come into the lottery topic with a bone to pick. I didn't, you know, I'm not a lottery winner, loser. I didn't, you know, none of my parents played growing up. But that is sort of what I, my conclusion, looking at the,
这本书叫《为了一美元和梦想：现代美国的州彩票》。非常感谢你，Jonathan，接受我们的采访。谢谢，祝你好运。《99% Invisible》本周由Jacob Moltenado Medina制作，Vivian Leigh编辑，原创音乐由Swan Riau创作，Martin Gonzales混音。Delaney Hall是高级编辑，Kurt Colstead
the net of evidence about the, about this issue. The book is called For a Dollar and a Dream State Lotteries in Modern America. Thank you so much, Jonathan, for talking with us. Thanks, and good luck. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jacob Moltenado Medina, edited by Vivian Leigh, original music by Swan Riau, sound mixed by Martin Gonzales. Delaney Hall is her senior editor, Kurt Colstead,
是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Christopher Johnson、Jason Delion、Chris Baroupe、Lashemba Dawn、Emmett Fitzgerald、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg，实习生Avanti Nambiar、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。《99% Invisible》由Stefan Lawrence创建。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的Pandora大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。
is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Christopher Johnson, Jason Delion, Chris Baroupe, Lashemba Dawn, Emmett Fitzgerald, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, in turn, Avanti Nambiar, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of the below goat was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, up town, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg，或者在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上关注。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc, or on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上关注我 @RomanMars，关注节目 @99PIorg，也可以在 Instagram、Reddit 和 TikTok 上关注我们。你可以在 99PI.org 找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。目前这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。